Call or go online now.
>> Sandra: FOX NEWS ALERT ON
THAT $900 BILLION CORONAVIRUS
AID PACKAGE HEADING TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S DESK FOR HIS
SIGNATURE.
THE PACKAGE PROVIDES $600
DIRECT PAYMENTS TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND EXTENDED
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS.
THE MASSIVE BILL DID NOT ESCAPE
HARSH CRITICISM FROM SOME
LAWMAKERS, 59 OF THEM.
NEARLY ALL REPUBLICANS DID NOT
VOTE FOR THAT BILL.
ONE OF THEM JOINS US NOW.
TEXAS CONGRESSMAN BRIAN BABIN.
WHY DID YOU CAST A NO VOTE?
>> IT WAS A NO-BRAINER FOR ME.
THERE IS SOME GOOD STUFF IN
THERE.
BUT THE PROCESS.
THIS IS NOT THE WAY OUR
GOVERNMENT IS SUPPOSED TO BE
WORKING.
THE PROCESS WAS A COMPLETE
FAILURE AND IT IS A DISGRACE TO
THE AMERICAN TAXPAYER.
THE BILL WAS NEARLY 6,000 PAGES
LONG.
EASILY ONE OF THE LARGEST BILLS
EVER PASSED IN CONGRESS.
IN FACT, IT WAS SO BIG THAT THE
PRINTING PRESSES BROKE DOWN AT
THE CAPITOL AND THE COMPUTERS
CRASHED.
SO THAT FURTHER DELAYED OUR
ABILITY TO EVEN ACTUALLY SEE
THE TEXT.
AND THEY GAVE US JUST A MATTER
OF A FEW HOURS TO READ 6,000
PAGES.
NO AMENDMENTS WERE ALLOWED.
NO COMMITTEE WORK FOR THE FINAL
PRODUCT.
JUST A HANDFUL OF MEMBERS AND
THEIR STAFFS WHO GATHERED IN
SECRET TO REALLY WRITE A 2.3
TRILLION DOLLAR BILL AND THE
REST OF US COULD TAKE IT OR
LEAVE IT.
TO DO SO IN LESS THAN FOUR
HOURS.
I BELIEVE IT WAS IRRESPONSIBLE
TO MY CONSTITUENTS AND THE REST
OF THE AMERICAN TAXPAYERS AND
TO VOTE ON SOMETHING OF THAT
MAGNITUDE AND NOT KNOW THE
DETAILS OF IT.
>> Sandra: AS WE ALL KNOW
DEMOCRATS BLAME REPUBLICANS FOR
HOLDING THIS UP.
REPUBLICANS BLAME DEMOCRATS FOR
NOT GETTING THIS DONE BACK IN
JULY.
HOW DID WE GET TO THIS POINT?
I MEAN, WE ARE -- WE’RE ALMOST
10 MONTHS INTO THAT PANDEMIC.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I’M GOING TO
-- ANYONE WHO IS ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE WATCHING THIS
PROGRAM MIGHT SAY HE IS JUST
BLAMING THE DEMOCRATS.
BUT LISTEN, SANDRA, MS. PELOSI
AND HER TEAM HAD EVERY
OPPORTUNITY.
IN FACT, IN EXCESS OF 40 TIMES
WE TRIED TO GET PPP PASSED AND
AUTHORIZED.
THERE WAS 137 BILLION DOLLAR
STILL SITTING THERE.
WE COULDN’T TOUCH IT BECAUSE
SHE WOULDN’T DEAL.
SO NOW WE HAVE IT.
IT WAS DONE AT THE LAST MINUTE
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS, AND AS I
SAID A SECOND AGO, THAT IS NOT
THE WAY TO RUN A RAILROAD.
AND I JUST DIDN’T FEEL LIKE IT
WAS A RESPONSIBLE THING FOR ME
TO DO TO VOTE FOR THAT.
AND VOTE ON SOMETHING THAT I
HADN’T READ.
YOU CAN’T READ 6,000 PAGES.
YOU CAN’T EVEN READ A SYNOPSIS
OF IT IN JUST A MATTER OF THE
TIME THAT THEY HAD GIVEN US.
AND I HAD ACTUALLY MADE
REQUESTS TO HAVE CERTAIN ITEMS
PUT INTO IT.
SOME OF THEM MADE IT EARLY ON.
BUT SOME OF THEM WERE NOT.
THEY SHUT THE DOOR AND HAD A
CLOSED OPERATION WHERE YOU
COULD NOT GET ANY AMENDMENTS
INTO IT.
>> Sandra: CONGRESSMAN, AS FAR
AS WHAT’S IN THE BILL WE COULD
DO OUR BEST TO SHOW OUR VIEWERS
WHAT WE KNOW SO FAR AS FAR AS
DOLLAR AMOUNTS FOR VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION, $69 BILLION, $22
BILLION TO STATES FOR TESTING
AND TRACING.
$7 BILLION FOR BROADBAND ACCESS
IS IN THE BILL.
$45 BILLION FOR TRANSPORTATION
AND TRANSIT AGENCIES.
RENTAL ASSISTANCE.
THE $600 THAT IS GOING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT IS SO
BADLY NEEDED.
DO YOU AGREE THIS WILL GO TO
SOME DEGREE TO HELPING
STRUGGLING AMERICANS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY.
THERE WAS SOME GOOD STUFF IN
THIS BILL.
THERE WAS ALSO CLIMATE CHANGE,
THERE WAS REDUCTION FOR ICE
FUNDING.
WE’VE GOT A WIDE OPEN SOUTHERN
BORDER THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
DONE AN AMAZING JOB TRYING TO
CONTROL WITHOUT ANY
CONGRESSIONAL HELP.
AND TO CUT ICE BY $431 MILLION
IS SIMPLY NOT A GOOD THING.
THERE IS ALSO SOME GUN CONTROL
IN THERE.
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
MONEY FOR THAT.
THERE WERE SOME THINGS IN THERE
THAT WERE GOOD.
THINGS THAT WERE BAD.
THE OVERALL PROCESS OF THE WAY
IT WAS PASSED, THE WAY IT WAS
DONE, THE MAGNITUDE OF IT AND
NO TIME TO REALLY STUDY IT WAS
WHAT MADE ME DECIDE TO VOTE
AGAINST IT.
>> Sandra: AND YOU CAST YOUR
VOTE NO AND YOU ARE HERE TO
TALK ABOUT IT THIS MORNING.
CONGRESSMAN, WE KNOW THAT’S
HEADED TO THE PRESIDENT’S DESK
AND EXPECTED TO SIGN IT THIS